votre mot préféré à
métamorphose le mot que vous détestez
si vous aimez le football je crois que
le mot qu'on aime le moins c'est arsenal
annonce l'équipe hays
votre drogue favorite à c'était les
villes le son le bruit que vous aimez de
téléphone le téléphone
bon bah j'espère pour vous annoncer une
bonne nouvelle un jour de la fatwa et
supprimer le son le bruit que vous
détestez
également le téléphone
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
mot blasphème j'ose pas le prononcer
devant vous parce que
ça nous rappelle de mauvais souvenirs
zut alors
un personnage qui décident de décrire
tous ces mots obscènes en jaune alors il
ils s'expriment ils jurent en jaune
alors c'est peut-être un peu ça jaune
jaune c'est bon homme ou femme pour
illustrer un nouveau billet de banque à
billets de banque en angleterre en
france ou en inde comme
woody allen pas mal très bien le métier
que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire preuve
de sécher hommes politiques laplante
l'arboux l'animal dans lequel vous
aimeriez être réincarné
fois qu'on aime bien le banyan c'est un
arbre qui peut trouver ses racines un
peu partout c'est ça alors vargas llosa
avait répondu l'hippopotame et sa
malheureuse jeudi avait répondu alors si
vous pertes aux échos avait répondu non
vous avez pondu une chaîne à bas mois
qu'il se soit trompé dans le non non non
non non vous avez dit jeudi un lieu de
et coopèrent pas ce n'est pas la réponse
mais non c'était le donc l'avènement
d'aucune bertrand vous aviez répondu
deux chaînes wii et vous avez un gars
très répandue le l'hippopotame si dieu
existe qu'aimeriez vous l'entendre vous
dire à vous salman rushdie quand vous
s'il existe et si vous quand vous
paraîtrez devant lui
demanderait de s'écarter parce qu'il m'a
déjà fait beaucoup de problèmes comme ça
de s'écarter
[Musique]